THIS IS THURSDAY JUNE. TWENTY
EIGHT WE'RE HAVING A SPECIAL
HEARING TO CLEAR OUT A NUMBER OF
BILLS.
THAT WE NEED TO BEFORE A FOR OUR
FISCAL DEADLINE.
SEE MR STERN IS HERE.
I DON'T SEE MISS MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
I JUST.
YOU'RE HERE YOU WANT GO FIRST SO
YOU KNOW IF FOR IT WITH LOVE AND
LET'S GO ALRIGHT THAT'S GOT SO
WOULD MEAN TO START WITH I SEE
MISTER WINNERS HERE YOU DO.
THOSE BILLS FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SUB JUST
FOURTEEN A SEVEN MISTER CHAIR
AND CENTER WIENER GONNA PRESENT.
TEN FORTY FIVE ON THIS LONESOME.
OKAY SO WE'LL START WITH S. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM SO WILL START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE [inaudible]
SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
GOING TO START BY TAKING THAT
COMMITTING STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
WORK AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING ALL
THE AMENDMENTS HERE TODAY.
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
PROHIBITS THE POSSESSION OF BODY
PARTS OF ELEVEN ICONIC AFTER
ENDANGERED SPECIES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE LOST SUDAN
THE LAST MALE WHITE RHINOCEROS --
ALL THE OTHER ICONIC ENDANGERED
SPECIES AFTER AND STRONG DECLINE
AND THERE'S A FALSE SENSE OUT
THERE THAT SOMEHOW HUNTING
PROMOTES CONSERVATION THE
PREMISE OF THIS BILL IS THERE'S
A MUCH BETTER WAY. TO SAVE THE
SPECIES BEEN GOING OUT TO KILL
THEM -- AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO PROMOTE --
HEALTHY ECO TOURISM INDUSTRY IN
THESE NATIONS --
BETTER METRICS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE SPECIES ARE DOING AND
GET CALIFORNIANS OUT OF THE
BLACK MARKET PLACE OF THESE.
OF THESE GOODS AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING A GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M GONNA CUT TO THE CHASE.
I JUST GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS --
TANZANIA.
IS ONE OF THE MOST FRIENDLY
HUNTING COUNTRIES IN AFRICA.
THAT COUNTRY LOST 60% OF ITS
ELEPHANTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
1060% AND THAT IS THE MOST
FRIENDLY HUNTING COMING UP
COUNTRY.
IN AFRICA --
SINCE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
LIVE POPULATIONS IN TANZANIA
WERE FOUND TO BE DOWN 66% FROM
THE NUMBERS JUST TWENTY YEARS
EARLIER.
THIS IS UP UP PLACE THAT ALONE
EXPORTED THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED
LINE TROPHY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
WITH OVER HALF OF THOSE COMING
INTO THE U. S..
CLEARLY TANZANIA'S MODEL OF
CONSERVING VIA THE HUNT IS NOT
WORKING --
IN RESPONSE THE DEVASTATING LOSS
OF LIFE AND TANZANIA AS WELL AS
IN NEIGHBORING ZIMBABWE AND
ZAMBIA THE U. S. FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE REQUESTED DATA
ON THEIR POPULATION.
AND IN COUNTRY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS BUT RECEIVED ONLY A
DOCUMENT FROM NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT OUTLINING GRAND INTENTIONS.
OF PROTECTING THESE ANIMALS BUT
OFFERING NO REAL CONSERVATION
PLANS WITH NO MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
IN PLACE IN OUT DATA POPULATION
DATA THE US FISH AND WILDLIFE
SERVICE HALTED ISSUING PERMITS.
FOR THESE ANIMALS.
YET DESPITE NO NEW INFORMATION.
COMING FROM THESE COUNTRIES NO
EXPLANATION OF THE MANAGEMENT
PLAN AND WHILE ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S IN BOB WHAT WAS IN THE
MIDST OF A COUP INTO THAT
SEVENTEEN THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION REVERSED THE
MORATORIUM ON IMPORTING THESE
TROPHIES.
WITH NO NEW INFORMATION
REGARDING THEIR NUMBERS OR THE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM --
OUT JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT THAT CAN I DO SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION BEFORE WE GET TO THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOD WHICH US THANKS.
RIGHT BUT IN SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CAP YOU WANT
REPRESENTING SPARK CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR
SPORTSMAN'S COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA.
COMPANIES SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY A
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL --
I WON'T BELABOR THE THE WILDLIFE
DISCUSSIONS SINCE WE HAVE THAT
WATER PARKS MY LIFE BUT WOULD
LIKE TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
LEGAL ISSUES --
FOR THIS COMMITTEE.
FIRST ABOUT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT GERMANE AS IT
WAS INTRODUCED AS A PUBLIC
UTILITIES CO BILL DEALING WITH
TRANSPORTATION.
AND IS NOW A FISHING GAME CODE
IN THE BILL WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY
AMENDED IN APRIL AFTER THE SPOT
BILL DEADLINE RULES DO MATTER.
BY THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO
REGULATE LEGAL HUNTING AFTER
THAT HAS BEEN DETERMINED --
AS PART OF THOSE COUNTRIES
MANAGEMENT PLANS THIS IS IN
CONFLICT WITH THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT FOR FOR
MANY SPECIES IN THE US INVALID
AND PREEMPTED.
I WON'T SPEND THE BULK OF MY
TIME ON THIS BUT THERE THESE
COUNTRIES DO MAKE SCIENCE BASED
DETERMINATIONS UP THERE RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT.
AND CALIFORNIA'S SITTING IN
JUDGMENT OF THE UNITED STATES
SPECIAL WILDLIFE SERVICES SITE
TO USE.
AN INTERNATIONAL UNION FOR
CONSERVATION.
IN MAKING A DETERMINATION ON HOW
TO MANAGE THEIR RESOURCES.
I WOULD JUST POINT OUT ONE
EXAMPLE THE PROPONENTS HAVE USED --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN BUT
BOTSWANA HAS STOPPED ON HUNTING --
AND THEY TELL THAT AS DISCUSSED
SUCCESS STORY OF AND IN FACT
THAT WAS DONE ON STATE AND
COMMUNAL LANDS NOT ON PRIVATE
LANDS IN SINCE THAT TIME
POACHING IS ACTUALLY INCREASED
AND HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS
HAVE INCREASED.
AND THEY HAVE NOW PETITION
LIBERAL PARTS OF THE STATE HAVE
NOW PETITION TO RE OPEN AND IN
FACT LAST WEEK ARM SOME OF THAT
WAS ACCOMPLISHED --
FOR NON USA SPECIES THERE IS NO
SCIENCE TO SUPPORT BANNING THE
IMPORTATION OF POSSESSION AND
FOR LISTINGS BASED UNITED FRUIT
FRESH IN MY LIFE SERVICES AS
JURISDICTION.
AND DETERMINE OF SCIENCE --
SO WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LITIGATION THIS IS DEFINITELY
GOING TO END UP IN THE COURTS.
OM AND THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY
HAD A SIMILAR LAW AND WIN THE
STATE REALIZED THAT THEY WERE
GONNA GET TOSSED THEY
INTERDEPENDENT DECREE.
THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WOULD
SUGGEST THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
SOMEHOW FIX THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALLOWING YOU TO COME INTO THIS
STATE.
LEGALLY HUNT LEGALLY POSSESS
LEGALLY TRANSPORT BUTTON THIRTY
ONE DAYS LATER YOU'RE A CRIMINAL.
I WOULD ARGUE THERE ASKING THE
OF THAT THE TAXPAYERS OF
CALIFORNIA TO BANKROLL LEGAL
ACTIONS IF THEY HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
RESOURCE THAN THEIR LAWSUIT
WOULD BE BETTER SERVED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
NOT ASKING CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
TO TAKE TAKE THE HIT FOR IT --
THEY HAVE SUGGESTED.
OF THAT THIS WOULD BE A
PRECEDENT --
THAT I THINK THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
PERHAPS WE DON'T LIKE --
THE WAY PEOPLE THAT CLOTHING OR
JEWELRY OR PERFUMES BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT HAVE MATERIALS ARE
CHEMICALS AND IN THAT WE DON'T
FIND APPROPRIATE.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN WHAT THAT'S
A TAKING --
SENATOR STERN HIMSELF ENJOY
SURFING AS A RECREATIONAL
PURSUIT SHOULD WE BAN --
SURFING IN AUSTRALIA BECAUSE IT
IMPACTS THE MARINE ECOSYSTEM AND
IT BRINGS A NICE SURFBOARD BACK
IN WE DON'T APPROVE OF THE WAY
THAT WAS MANUFACTURED OR MADE UP
SOME WOOD SPECIES WE DON'T
APPROVE OF SHOULD THAT NOW
BECOME FOR SKATED FROM HIM.
THIRTY ONE DAYS LATERS PHAM I
REALLY ASK YOU TO GIVE THOUGHT
TO THE PRESIDENT SENDING NATURE
OF THE US.
CALIFORNIANS OFF YOU TO WRAP
OKAY CALIFORNIANS ALSO BUT*
WAY OUT AND SO THERE'S ALSO --
SOME LIABILITY FOR THE STATE
THERE THE ISSUE OF IVORY IS
OFTEN MENTIONED BUT I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT'S FOR COMMERCIAL
SALE.
NOT THIS IS FOR PRIVATE PERSONAL
POSSESSION AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF ISSUES WITH WHO ARE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITY GONNA BE
THAT'S GOING TO APPROVE THIS
WHAT KIND OF PAPERWORK ARE GONNA
HAVE THERE'S A LOT OF
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER --
PUBLIC ESTABLISHMENTS THAT HAVE
SUCH SPECIES HOW WERE THEY GOING
TO BE OF THE DOCUMENT THAT AND
OUR FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE'S
HAS A BACK FILL IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T MANAGE THEIR OWN
RESOURCES.
SO I THINK THAT WE'D BE BETTER
POSITIONED TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS
HERE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT SEE NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
WE HAVE OKAY WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A POOR FOR SO KALRA
PLEASE STONE HERE CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KILEY THEIR MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES HERE MCCARTY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
AND I WILL NOTICE THAT MR
MCCARTY IT'S GOING TO BE JOINING
US TODAY TO FEEL FILL OUR
OTHERWISE ABSENT SLOTS.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THAT
MEANS MISTER CHU WILL TAKE A
MOTION.
AND AS ARE SET SECOND SECOND
ISRAEL'S.
RIGHT QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE STRICTLY US RIVAL.
THANK YOU SO THIS MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CHAU [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN AYE AYE HOLDEN
AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES AYE MCCARTY.
THANK MEMBERS THAT THE BILL IS
ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR LEADERS.
OKAY SO WILL TAKE SENATOR
SKINNER ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B..
NINE EIGHTY FOUR CENTER WE KNOW
THAT'S OKAY.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ON S. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
SENATOR --
IT'S A GREAT BILL ALLOW MY
WITNESSES TO PRESENT AND DAD
NEVER TALKED PASSED YES.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MA YOU FOR
HIM AND I AM AN ATTORNEY WITH
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
AREAS A NATIONAL NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION BASED IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND OUR MISSION.
IS TO PROTECT AND EXPAND
ECONOMIC AND EDUCATIONAL ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS WE'VE BEEN PURSUING THIS
MISSION FOR OVER FORTY YEARS.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE CO SPONSORS OF
SP NINETY FOUR WHICH WILL ENSURE
GREATER REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN
ON APPOINTED BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND REQUIRE DATA COLLECTION IN
TRANSPARENCY REGARDING THE
GENDER COMPOSITION OF THESE
ENTITIES.
WHILE WOMEN MAKE UP 50% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION THEY
CONTINUE TO BE UNDER REPRESENTED
IN GOVERNMENT AND BUSINESS AND
IN LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN
GENERAL.
WOMEN CURRENTLY REPRESENT JUST
23% OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
THIS MEANS THAT ONLY ONE IN FOR
LEGISLATORS ARE WOMEN.
AND INDEED WITHOUT POSITIVE
EFFORTS LIKE S. B. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR PROGRESS FOR WOMEN IS
CERTAINLY NOT LINEAR. THIRTY
POINT 8% OF THE LEGISLATURE WERE
WOMEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX ON
THE BUSINESS SIDE IN A STUDY OF
THREE THOUSAND GLOBAL COMPANIES
WOMEN WERE FOUND A WHOLE JUST
FOURTEEN POINT SEVEN OF BOARD
SEATS IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN JUST TWENTY SEVEN
WOMEN LED FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
COMPANIES.
DIVERSITY IS NOT JUST IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE IN MATTERS BECAUSE
DIVERSE LEADERSHIP SHOWN TO
PRODUCE BETTER RESULTS.
IMPORTANTLY THE BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE COLLECTION OF AND
RELEASE OF DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
PROVIDED BY ALL STATE BOARD AND
COMMISSION APPLICANTS THE
NOMINEES ARE APPOINTEES.
RELATED TO ETHNICITY RACE GENDER
GENDER IDENTITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION THIS TRANSPARENCY IS
CRITICAL FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS WHO
WORK TO REPRESENT WOMEN.
AND PURSUE DIVERSITY IN THE
COURTS AND IN OUR LAWS.
MEMBERS OF STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS PLAN ACTIVE ROLE IN
GUIDING IMPORTANT POLICY
DECISIONS AND GUIDING AND
VALUING IMPORTANT CIVIL RIGHTS.
THEREFORE WE NEED LEADERS WITH
DIVERSE SKILL SETS BACKGROUNDS
AND INVALUABLE PERSPECTIVE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR S. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR
AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FIX WITH US PLEASE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON JESSE
RYAN I'M EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
AND I'M ALSO PROUD GRADUATE OF
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE I'M
STRONGLY URGING YOUR AYE VOTE ON
NINE EIGHTY FOUR I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT LAST NIGHT I STUMBLED
ACROSS MY HUSBAND READING ALOUD
TO MY EIGHT YEAR OLD.
READING AN OPEN LETTER TO THE
WOMEN WHO WILL RUN THE WORLD.
MY DAUGHTER BROOKLYN IS AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND SHE'S NOT OFTEN
REPRESENTED IN THE BOARD ROOMS
OR ELECTED OFFICE WE'VE SAID TO
BROOKLYN THAT AS YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE NOT ON THE TABLE YOU'RE
ON THE MENU.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS DIVERSE REPRESENTATION
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVES WHICH WE
KNOW ARE KEY TO GOOD GOVERNANCE.
I'LL ABBREVIATE MY REMARKS AND I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THIS VERY IMPORTANT BELL I
DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT S. B. NINE EIGHTY FOUR HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO TRANSFORM THE
COMPOSITION OF CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP.
IF YOU SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT JUST STATE
HOW MUCH YOU VALUE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN BUT
ILLUSTRATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
LITTLE GIRLS LIKE MY DAUGHTER.
BY ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE A
SEAT AT THE DECISION MAKING
TABLE AND IN FACT THAT THEY ARE
NOT ON THE MENU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS AND SUPPORTS.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION.
JOHN MICHAEL FOR EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE SENATOR REMAIN CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR I THINK IT A THE
ADDITIONAL BENEFIT BESIDES THAT
WAS MENTIONED BY MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IS THAT IT PUTS
CALIFORNIA IN A LEADERSHIP
POSITION.
AND THE POSITION THAT SETS A
MODEL FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WHICH WE HOPE WILL BE EMULATED
WITHOUT ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
BUT THANK YOU AND CENTER YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
AS FOR YES YES THANK YOU EVER.
SO THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CHECK OUT.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES.
REYES AYE MCCARTY.
THAT BUILDS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU RIGHT SENATOR WIENER YOU
HAVE S. B. [inaudible]
TEN FORTY FIVE IT'S
AND MAYOR
WELCOME.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF ARE FOR WORKING
WITH US EXTENSIVELY ON THIS BILL.
AYE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED.
I AMENDMENTS ON ALSO HONORED TO
BE JOINED HERE TODAY --
BY THE MAYOR ELECT OF SAN
FRANCISCO LONDON BREED WHO WILL
BE SWORN IN ON A JULY ELEVENTH --
AND ALSO RAFEAL MAN THE MAN WHO
WAS RECENTLY ELECTED TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TO THE SEA THAT I USE.
TO OUR HOLD ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND I THANK THEM FOR
BEING HERE.
ARE WITH US TODAY TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
FUND AS AMENDED I SP.
TEN FORTY FIVE CREATES A NEW
CONSERVATORSHIP AYE IN THE
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE.
OUGHT TO ALLOW --
FOR APPOINTED FOR PERSON OF WHO
IS INCAPABLE OF CARING OFFER
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
I DO TOO SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
AYE AND SEVERE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER EYES EVIDENCE BY
FREQUENT DETENTION FOR
EVALUATION AND TREATMENT.
PURSUANT TO SECTION FIFTY ONE
FIFTY OF THE WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODES.
OF THE BILL IS A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM THOUGHT FOR A SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTIES.
ODD THIS CONSERVATORSHIP WILL
PROVIDE FOR THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE AND MOST CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT INCLUDING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHEREVER
POSSIBLE.
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT CREATING A
NARROW TOOL. TO CARE FOR THE
MOST VULNERABLE I'VE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AYE ISSUES AND
WHO ARE --
IN MANY CASES TRAGICALLY DYING
ON OUR STREETS.
BECAUSE THIS IS A TINY SUBSET OF
OUR POPULATION.
SAN FRANCISCO FOR EXAMPLE
ESTIMATES THAT APPROXIMATELY 1%
OF OUR HOMELESS POPULATION.
WOULD MEET THE CRITERIA AND THE
SPELL.
THIS DOES NOT APPLY TO THE BASS
MAJORITY OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION --
WHEN PEOPLE ARE WE SEE PEOPLE
WHO ARE DYING ON OUR STREETS
PEOPLE WHO ARE?
SLEEPING IN THEIR FAECES ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WHO ARE BY ANY
DEFINITION.
FALLING APART ON OUR STREETS OF
PEOPLE WALK BY.
AND THEY WONDER AND THEY GET
ANGRY WHY IS NO ONE DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS.
AND THE REASON IS THAT OUR
CURRENT CONSERVATORSHIP LAWS
WHICH WERE CONSTRUCTED A LONG
TIME AGO OR NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THIS TINY SUBSET OF THE
POPULATION.
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND WHO AFTER
A SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD MAY
SOBER UP AND APPEAR PERFECTLY
NORMAL WHEN THEY GO BEFORE A
JUDGE.
NEVER MIND THAT THEY'VE BEEN
FIFTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN TIMES IN
THE LAST YEAR AND PROBABLY WILL
BE AGAIN.
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS.
LIKE ALL CONSERVATIVE SHIPS AND
I I AM VERY VERY MINDFUL
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS NEED TO BE WE
NEED TO HANDLE THEM WITH GREAT
CARE.
BECAUSE THIS IS BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE'S CIVIL LIBERTIES WERE
TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
THIS BILL.
LIKE OTHER CONSERVATIVE SHIPS
MAINS MAINTAINS STRONG DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE
FOR WHOM CONSERVATORSHIP IS
SOUGHT.
JUDICIAL OVERSIGHT A RIGHT TO
TRIAL BY JURY --
REPRESENTATION BY COUNSEL AND
PERIODIC REVIEW BY THE COURT.
BOB THIS FOCUSES ON THE PEOPLE
WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
AND TO BE CLEAR OUR GOAL HERE IS
HOUSING AND SERVICES NOT LOCKED
FACILITIES WHILE THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE.
WHO MAY NEED A LOCKED FACILITY
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE CONSERVED DO
NOT AND IN FACT IN SAN FRANCISCO?
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN CONSERVATIVE
SHIPS WHO WERE LIVING IN SUPPORT
OF HOUSING.
AND THAT IS ALWAYS THE GOAL
HOUSING AND SERVICES
[inaudible]
ON SO OUR OUR EXISTING LAWS ARE
NOT ENOUGH --
WE NEED TO UPDATE THEM WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PILOT PROGRAM
WILL ALLOW US OUGHT TO DO THAT.
I SO AGAIN WITH ME TODAY ARE
MAYOR ELECT BREED AND A
SUPERVISOR ELECT ARMANDO MEN --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS PLATES.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND CHAIR STONE --
MY NAME IS LINDENBERG EAT I AM
STILL A MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND THE MAYOR ELECT. FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE
WITH YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL --
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND THANK
SENATOR SCOTT WIENER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
ISSUE -- SP
TEN FOUR FIVE HELPS CRITICAL
NEED IN SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE IT
OFFERS US A WAY TO HELP SOME OF
OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS WHO ARE NOT
JUST SUFFERING ON OUR STREETS
AND CAN'T CARE FOR THEMSELVES
WITH PEOPLE WHO SADLY ARE ALSO
DYING ON OUR STREETS.
THIS COULD HAPPEN TO ANYONE OF
US AT ANY GIVEN TIME TO ANY ONE
OF OUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND IT'S
THE REAL TRAGIC UNFORTUNATE
EXPERIENCE.
BUT OUR CURRENT LAWS MAKE IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT --
AND I KNOW THAT IF IT WERE ME IF
I WERE OUT THERE STRUGGLING --
IN THIS PARTICULAR WAY I'D WANT
SOMEONE TO HELP I WANT SOMEONE
TO STEP IN.
OUR CITY DOES HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF PROVIDING
COMPASSIONATE CARE AND WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT LIMITING
ANYONE'S CIVIL LIBERTIES MUST BE
APPROACHED WITH CAUTION.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE CAN'T
IGNORE THE HEARTBREAKING SCENES
THAT WE SEE EVERY SINGLE DAY I
HAVE PEOPLE ON MY PERSONAL
CASELOAD PEOPLE THAT I HAVE
TRIED TO HELP THAT I'VE GOTTEN
INTO OUR SHELTER SYSTEM. ONE
INDIVIDUAL IN PARTICULAR WHO IS
UNFORTUNATELY A SCHIZOPHRENIC HE
HAS CHALLENGES WITH A DRUG ABUSE --
HE IS A SENIOR CENTER SEND OUR
PEOPLE LOVE HIM IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THEY WANT TO HELP HIM BUT
EVERY NOW AND THEN THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES WHEN HE CATCHES
HIS CHECK AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE MONTH HE ALWAYS GETS ITS
MONEY TAKEN BY.
OTHER PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS HE
GETS INTO WITH THE POLICE HAVE
MANY APOLOGIZES LATER WE'VE HAD
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIM
BUT HE NEEDS SUPPORT HE NEEDS A
GUARDIAN HE NEEDS SOMEONE. TO
SUPPORT AND HELP LOOK AFTER HIM
BECAUSE HE CLEARLY CANNOT MAKE
DECISIONS FOR HIMSELF I HAVE
OTHER FOLKS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
THIS IS JUST IN MY DISTRICT.
WHO HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO WANT
TO SUPPORT THEM BUT THE CURRENT
LAWS MAKE IT SO DIFFICULT AND IN
ALL OF THESE INSTANCES THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY?
IN THEIR SIXTIES.
AND THEY'RE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS.
AND WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING MORE
THIS IS A TOOL THAT CAN HELP US
GET TO A BETTER PLACE.
AND WE KNOW THAT FOR A SMALL
SUBSET OF THIS POPULATION THE
COMBINE A FACT OF UNTREATED
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER.
IS DEVASTATING AND LEAVES THEM
UNABLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES WE
SEE MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
ACROSS MANY SYSTEMS OF CARE
SEVERAL TIMES A YEAR.
AND WE CAN BREAK THE CYCLE WE
CAN TO PREVENT THEM FROM CYCLING
IN AND OUT OF OUR HOSPITALS AND
IN AND OUT OF OUR JAIL SYSTEMS
WE ARE CURRENTLY.
USING OUR JAILS TO HOUSE PEOPLE
WHO NEED TREATMENT.
S. B. TEN FOUR FIVE HELPS US DO
JUST THAT.
WE KNOW THAT WITH ENOUGH TIME
ENOUGH SUPPORT THE RIGHT
SERVICES THAT WE CAN HELP PEOPLE
RECOVER BUT IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN BE HEALTHY.
THEY CAN BE HOW THEY CAN BE
STABILIZE FOR THE LONG TERM THEY
NEED A GUARDIAN THEY NEED AN
ADVOCATE SOMEONE WHO CAN MAKE
DECISIONS FOR THEM BECAUSE THEY
CLEARLY CANNOT MAKE DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES.
WITH THIS BILL WE SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP PEOPLE GET
STABILIZE AND A SAFE PLACE TO
SLEEP AT NIGHT AND ACCESS TO
INTENSIVE TARGETED SERVICES WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT MAKING A
MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF WHAT I'M OUNCE.
TO LESS THAN 1% OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATION IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE
WE HAVE UP IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
HOMELESSNESS IS OF COURSE A
BROADER ISSUE IT REQUIRES A
NUMBER OF SOLUTIONS TO GET TO A
BETTER PLACE.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HELP AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
ON THAT WE'RE NOT JUST ALLOW --
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T CARE FOR
THEMSELVES ARE TO BE ON THEIR
OWN TO BE LEFT ON OUR STREETS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE RIGHTS AND I
KNOW THAT'S A HARSH THING TO SAY.
BUT THE FACT IS WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS NOT HUMANE.
IT'S NOT COMPASSION AND WE CAN
DO BETTER.
SAN FRANCISCO IS READY AND
WILLING TO SUPPORT THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN FACT WE JUST
OPENED FIFTY FOUR MENTAL HEALTH
STABILIZATION BEDS AND ABOUT
THIRTY THREE OF THOSE ARE
OCCUPIED.
OUR ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN SUPPORT PEOPLE
THAT THEY CAN LIVE ON THEIR OWN
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THAT THEY
HAVE AN ADVOCATE AND SOMEONE.
WHO CAN MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
SAFE AND THAT THEY ARE HEALTHY
AND THEY'RE GETTING THE SO
SUPPORT AND SERVICES THAT WE
NEED AND WE HOPE THAT S. B.?
TEN FOUR FIVE WILL BEA TOOL
THAT CAN HELP ADDRESS THIS VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUE AND I HOPE WE
CAN COUNT ON YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
TO MOVE IT FORWARD THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS AYE I
GAVE THE MAYOR ELECT QUITE A BIT
OF LATITUDE I'M GONNA HOLD YOU
THREE MINUTES.
I WON'T EVEN TAKE THREE LAURIE
[inaudible]
A GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE STONE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
AS SENATOR WIENER.
SAID I'M RAFEAL MANDOLIN I AM --
THE NEW NEWLY ELECTED MEMBER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
ON AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B. TEN
FORTY FIVE AND THANK SENATOR
WIENER FOR TAKING ON A DIFFICULT
BUT VERY IMPORTANT.
BUILT OVER THE LAST YEAR OF CAMP
FOLKS THROUGHOUT --
MY DISTRICT I'VE TALKED TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND NO WAY SHE WAS
MORE FRUSTRATING FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS AND NO PUB PUBLIC
POLICY FAILURE IS MORE OBVIOUS.
PAINFUL AND EMBARRASSING TO OUR
CITY THAT OUR INABILITY TO
PROVIDE CARE TO SO MANY
OBVIOUSLY SICK PEOPLE ON OUR
STREETS AND IN OUR PUBLIC SPACES.
FOR ME IT'S PERSONAL MY MOTHER
SUFFERED FROM MENTAL ILLNESS
MUCH OF HER LIFE AND SPENT TIME
IN A HOMELESS SHELTER WHEN I WAS
YOUNG.
I KNOW FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNABLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES
AND IT IS UNREASONABLE TO EXPECT
THOSE PEOPLE TO VOLUNTARILY
ACCESS SERVICES.
AND YET THAT IS PRECISELY WHAT
WE DO.
AS A LAW STUDENT I WORK TO GET
INSTITUTIONALIZED PATIENTS INTO
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE LIVING
ENVIRONMENT BUT THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE LIVING ENVIRONMENT
CANNOT BE A SIDEWALK. TOO MANY
OF OUR NEIGHBORS LIVE ON A
RELENTLESS AND COSTLY MERRY GO
ROUND THAT CARRIES THEM FROM THE
STREETS TO THE HOSPITAL BACK TO
THE STREETS TO JAIL AND AROUND
AND AROUND AND AROUND AND IT IS
INHUMANE.
IT IS EXPENSIVE AND IT HAS TO
STOP.
SAN FRANCISCO DID NOT CREATE
THIS PROBLEM BUT WE ARE DOING
OUR BEST TO SOLVE IT PLEASE GIVE
US THIS DESPERATELY NEEDED TOOL.
TO MOVE THE VERY SICKEST AND
MOST EXPENSIVE FOLKS OFF THE
STREETS AND INTO CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
DEFEAT GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION I'D KILL
NIELSEN WAS SAN FRANCISCO'S
OFFICE OF THE PUBLIC CONSERVATOR
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN FORTY FIVE AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE.
HELLO MY NAME IS HEATHER BERNICE
AND I'M WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
TEAM.
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT AND CAN BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
KILLING HER MOTTO DIRECTOR OF
TRANSITIONS WITH CENSUS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT CNN OPPOSITION
.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KERR CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
A DISABILITY RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
MENTAL HEALTH --
ORGANIZATIONS HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND HOMELESS
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE ALL BEEN
OPPOSED TO THE APPROACH THAT SAN
FRANCISCO HAS DECIDED TO TAKE --
TO WHETHER WE AGREE IS CERTAINLY.
REGRETTABLE SITUATION ON OUR
STREETS AND ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO A DESPITE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
BILL -- AND
REALLY THAT'S FOR TWO REASONS
WE'VE SPENT DECADES AT THE END
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
WORKING TOWARD DE
INSTITUTIONALIZING.
AND THAT IS A CENTERPIECE TO THE
WORK THAT WE DO WHETHER THAT BE --
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS WHETHER THAT
BE IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
ABLE TO LIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED TO STAY
AND LIVE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SECONDLY WE HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW THAT IS AT
LEAST I WILL SAY IN THE CONTEXT
OF CONSERVATORSHIP IS REALLY A
BROKEN SYSTEM.
AND TO TRY AND OPEN THOSE GATES
WIDER TO FORCE INDIVIDUALS INTO
THAT SYSTEM WITHOUT THE
ASSURANCE OF SERVICES WHETHER
THAT'S SUPPORTIVE HOUSING --
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ENSURING
THAT THERE'S A MENTAL HEALTH
CARE BE --
PHYSICAL HEALTH CARE ALL
PROVIDED TO SURE --
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY DO
IN FACT HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO RESIDE IN IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IT AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE ONE
OTHER COMMENT ON THE FACT THAT --
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA --
IS THE LARGEST DISABILITY RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION IN THIS COUNTRY WE
HAVE OVER TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OR A
HUNDRED LAWYERS THAT WORK ON
THESE ISSUES WE KNOW THE
POPULATION WELL.
WE DO LITIGATION IN THE JAILS
CONCERNING THE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE WE WE UNDERSTAND WELL I'D I
HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD
NOT WALK AWAY AND I KNOW IT IS
NOT THE INTENT --
THAT OUR POSITION IS INDEED AND
IN HUMANE POSITION WE TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO ASSURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE RECEIVING
THE CARE.
THAT I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK THE THE HELP THAT YOU
COMMITTEE COUNSEL BOTH HERE AND
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'VE HAD.
AT I THINK IN CRAFTING A SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL MAKE THIS
BILL -- A
LOT STRONGER BILL FOR ASSURING
WHAT WE'VE STARTED AS NECESSARY
IT AND THESE AMENDMENTS DO SOME
I FLEW FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE VERY
KEY THINGS.
TIME LIMITS THIS PROJECT MAKES
IT A PILOT PROJECT --
THE COUNTY MUST DEVELOP AN UP
FRONT PLAN ON HOW THEY WOULD
IMPLEMENT --
THE PROJECT AND IMPORT THE THAT
HAS TO BE DONE WITH THE
INVOLVEMENT OF STAKEHOLDERS AND
DISABILITY RIGHTS AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT --
THAT IT MUST ACTUALLY BE ADOPTED
BY THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ONCE.
ONCE THERE IS A PLAN AND THERE
MUST BE A COMMITMENT OF THE
ASSURANCES THAT THERE WILL BE
SERVICES PROVIDED --
AND WRAPAROUND DE HOUSING --
AND I THINK THAT CENTRAL THEME
THROUGHOUT THE THE AMENDMENTS IS
THIS MUST BE DONE IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE --
ALTERNATIVE AND WE THINK THAT'S
ESSENTIAL --
BUT WE DO WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT THAT YOU TINKERING
WITH --
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENTS IS NOT
THE ANSWER TO THE PROBLEM THAT
EXISTS IN OUR CITY COUNTY
STREETS RIGHT NOW.
IT IS FUNDAMENTALLY A LACK OF
HOUSING.
AND FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A LACK OF HOUSING
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES THAT ARE
NOT BEING MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM
THAT'S THE ANSWER AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT THE THIS COMMITTEE AND
AND WE KNOW --
CERTAINLY THE THE SITTING.
CSCO STAYS FOCUSED ON THIS
THAT'S THE REAL ANSWER THAT'S
THE REAL SOLUTION THAT WE NEED
TO GET TO AND THAT --
WE SUPPORT SO AGAIN I THINK THIS
MAKES -- A
MUCH BETTER BILL A IF YOU HAVE
TO STEP INTO A WORLD OF
INVOLUNTARY --
CARE BUT BECAUSE I IT IT IS
STILL INVOLUNTARY IT HAS THE
INVOLUNTARY NESS OPTION
ULTIMATELY TODAY AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE OOD
AFTERNOON CHEN FLOOR ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- I
REITERATE HER CHILD'S COMMENTS
REGARDING THE AMENDMENTS I MEAN
I THINK WE ARE GOING DOWN THE
PATH OF CONSERVATORSHIP WE'VE
ADDED MORE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS --
AND AND IMPORTANTLY DE
INCENTIVIZING CRIMINALIZING
HOMELESSNESS THOSE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO WESTERN CENTER I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND IDENTIFYING THOSE
ISSUES.
HOWEVER SP TEN FORTY FIVE IN
MANY WAYS REPRESENTS A COMPLETE
FAILURE OF UPSTREAM SOLUTIONS TO
AVOID THE PROBLEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE I THINK MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
LIFE.
THERE COULD HAVE BEEN AN
INTERVENTION WHERE SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES
EARLY MENTAL HEALTH OR DRUG.
PROBABLY NOTHING I SAY HERE IS
GOING TO STOP THIS BILL FROM
BEING PASSED TO COMMITTEE AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF THOSE
VOTES TODAY ARE COMING FROM A
REAL AND GENUINE PLACE OF
WANTING TO DO SOMETHING.
FROM HUMAN COMPASSION.
SO IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN I
ALSO OFFER THIS CHALLENGE
CONSERVATORSHIP CAN'T BE OUR
SAFETY NET.
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS THE UN
HUMAN RIGHTS COUNCIL HAS SENT
SPECIAL RAPPORTEURS ON HOUSING
RIGHTS AND ON EXTREME POVERTY TO
BOTH SAN FRANCISCO AND LA AND
THE CONDITIONS THEY DESCRIBED
WERE SO DEPLORABLE AND SO
SKATING.
THAT IS A LARGE PART OF THE
REASON THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PULLED THE U. S.
OUT OF THE UN HUMAN RIGHTS
COUNCIL.
NO WHERE IN THEIR REPORTS DID
THEY IDENTIFY THE LACK OF
CONSERVATORSHIP SINCE THE
BECAUSE OF EXTREME HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS THAT ARE ENCOURAGING.
INSTEAD THEY IDENTIFIED A
FAILURE TO CONTROL THE REAL
ESTATE MARKET A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING
THE CRIMINALIZATION OF POVERTY
INCLUDING SWEEPS OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND REMOVING THEIR
POSSESSIONS.
AND OTHER STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS
SUCH AS OUR TAX POLICY.
MANY OF THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE CAN'T TAKE ON
NOW I BELIEVE SENATOR WIENER
THAT HIS INTENT FOR THIS BILL IS
TO DETER ADDRESS A VERY
PARTICULAR SUBSET OF PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT CARE FOR THEMSELVES.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
THE ONLY INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL
DIE LIVING ON THE STREET.
EVERY YEAR HUNDREDS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS DIE FROM EXPOSURE
FROM VIOLENCE FROM TREATABLE
DISEASE NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNAWARE OF HOW TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES BUT BECAUSE SOCIETY
HAS FAILED.
SO IF YOU'RE VOTING FOR THIS
TODAY BECAUSE SOMETHING MUST BE
DONE ABOUT THE CRISIS WE ARE
FACING IN OUR STREETS THEN I
ALSO ASK FOR YOURPARTNERSHIP.
IN STOPPING THE ARRESTS OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVING ON THE
STREETS WE'VE TRIED AT WESTERN
CENTER TO ENACT A HOMELESS BILL
OF RIGHTS IN THIS YEAR WE COULD
EVEN GET AN AUTHOR.
PASSING BASIC JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS FOR ADDICTION.
FAILED THIS YEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY.
ENSURING THAT MENTAL HEALTH ACT
SERVICES DOLLARS ARE SPENT AS IT
INTENDED AND THAT LOCALITY
SENIOR DISTRICT ARE NOT BLOCKING
THE CONSTRUCTION OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
FUNDING THE CONSTRUCTION OF OF
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
AVOIDING THE DISPLACEMENT OF LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ADEQUATELY
FUNDING OTHER SAFETY NET
SERVICES SUCH AS CASH BENEFITS
AND HEALTH CARE.
TAKING AWAY AN INDIVIDUAL'S
FREEDOM EVEN IF FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY IS A SERIOUS MATTER AND
DEMOCRACY WE CANNOT GO THERE IF
WE ARE NOT HONESTLY DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO AVOID SUCH
SITUATIONS.
SO WHILE WE STILL REMAIN OPPOSED
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
PEOPLE IN PARTNERSHIP TO ADDRESS
THESE OTHER SITUATIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION.
JERRY MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA.
ALLEN GOOD MOTIVES DON'T JUSTIFY
MISGUIDED ACTIONS ANYMORE THAN
BAD MOTIVES.
WE UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN OPPOSED
BUT WITH APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THAT THAT
AMENDMENTS INTAKE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KELLY ROSENBERG WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS THAT
REPRESENT THE WORKERS TO PROVIDE
THESE NECESSARY SERVICES AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED AND THE COURT
WORKERS TO HELP GET THEM --
THROUGH THE SYSTEM WE ARE ALSO
AN UNFORTUNATE POSITION TO TO
THE SHORTFALL FUNDING AND OTHER --
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY OUR
ALLIES THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK
[inaudible]
TO THAT COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT POSITION.
AND I ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT.
SERVICE SHIPS NOT NECESSARILY
THE RIGHT TOOL HERE.
BUT WE HAVE SUCH AN EXPLOSION IN
SUCH A CHALLENGE WITH DEALING
WITH WITH HOMELESS [inaudible]
THAT.
I APPLAUD HIM JUST GO FOR REALLY
TRY TO TAKE THE RIGHT STEPS BUT
I THINK.
WE CAN ALSO SEE SOME OF THE
HOLES IN THE OVERALL SYSTEM WE
DO HAVE A FRACTURED MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE COUNTIES THAT ARE
TAKING A LOT OF PROP SIXTY THREE
MONEY BUT CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW
TO SPEND IT.
PART OF THAT ARE THE COUNTIES
ISSUES BECAUSE THERE ARE A BUT
UNWILLINGNESS TO SPEND OR LACK
OF A STRUCTURE SPEND IT PART
THAT'S THE STATE.
INCLUDING SO MANY IMPEDIMENTS IN
PLACE.
THAT LOW LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
AFRAID TO SPEND THE MONEY AND
THEY'RE AFRAID TO SPEND THE
MONEY IN WAYS THAT.
THAT THEY'RE ALSO THREATENED BY
NOT BE ABLE TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
MONIES SO WE HAVE A CONCURRENCE
OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
THAT ARE JUST NOT WORKING.
AND PEOPLE ARE ABSOLUTELY
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS.
SO FOR US WE REALLY STRUGGLED
WITH THIS BILL THIS NOTION OF OF
CONSERVING PEOPLE LOCKING PEOPLE
UP TAKING AWAY.
THEIR FREEDOMS THAT'S ULTIMATELY
NOT THE ANSWER.
BUT TRYING TO FIND A WAY. TO
GIVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS SOME
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY'RE
FINDING ON THEIR DOORSTEP.
IS ALSO SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THAT REPRESENTS AT THIS POINT
AND WHY.
THE I'M RECOMMENDING THAT WE
THAT WE DO PASSED THIS BILL OUT.
BUT WITH SOME CAUTIONS WHAT I
DON'T WANT TO SEE IN THIS IS A
FIVE YEAR PILOT AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE WATCHING SAM CISCO AND AL
A TO HEAR HOW THIS GETS
IMPLEMENTED.
BECAUSE I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT
OTHER CHICK JURISDICTIONS AND
SAY WELL LOOK WHAT'S AND CISCO'S
DOING GIVE US THAT SAME ABILITY.
WITHOUT THE WILLINGNESS TO PUT
SUPPORTIVE PROGRAMS IN PLACE FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
CONSERVING.
AND SO SAN FRISCO IS NOT ABLE TO
DO THAT OR IS UNWILLING TO DO
THAT JUST PUTTING SOMEBODY ELSE
IN CHARGE OF SOMEONE'S LIFE OR
ENDING UP LOCKING SOMEBODY UP
TAKING THEIR FREEDOMS AWAY FROM
THEM.
IS REALLY NOT GOING TO BE THE
ANSWER.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
VIGILANT IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW
AND ARE GOING TO NEED SEARCHES
GOING LA'S SUPPORT.
AS THIS MOVE FORWARD.
TO SHOW US HOW THIS COULD WORK.
OR WHAT THE NEXT STEPS ARE THEN.
IF WE'RE GONNA ALLOW THIS TO
MOVE THAT WE THEN PROTECT
AGAINST SOME OF THE FEARS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP.
SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S BEFORE
US TODAY IS TO SEE OKAY.
GIVE IT A SHOT AND I THINK
ANYBODY CAN FIGURE THIS OUT
PROBABLY DESERVES CISCO YOU'VE
SHOWN A WILLINGNESS TO RAISE
FUNDS YOUR SON A WILLINGNESS TO
INVEST IN APPROPRIATE PLACES.
SO LET'S MAKE SURE THAT THIS
WORKS.
OTHERWISE THERE'S GOING TO BE
THIS LONG PRESSURE ON US TO SAY
WILL LET US DO THE SAME THING.
FROM JURISDICTIONS THAT MAY NOT
BE.
AS WELL POSITIONED MAY NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES MAY NOT REALLY BE
WILLING.
THEY'LL TAKE A TOOL AND APPLY IT
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE WOULD WANT
TO SEE HAPPEN THAT'S KIND OF
SOME OF THE DANGER THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH HERE.
THAT'S TO TRUST THAT WERE
POLICING IN YOU BY MOVING THE
BILL [inaudible]
AND THAT OUR OBLIGATION IS.
TO DO THE OVERSIGHT TO WATCH TO
SEE HOW THIS WORKS AND IF IT CAN
WORK AND IF WE GET A MODEL BACK.
OF HOW WE CAN ADDRESS CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS AND THE AND THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN CITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
BUILD ON AND BRING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. TO THE TABLE AND
SEE HOW WE CAN REALLY IMPROVE IT.
BUT CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
GONNA HAVE TO SPEND THEM THE
PROP SIXTY THREE MONEY THAT THEY
HAVE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIX.
THE SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM AT THE
STATE LEVEL HOPING WITH THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION WE CAN.
CAN PUSH THAT EVEN HARDER HERE
AND HAVE THE SERVICES AVAILABLE
AND REALLY INVEST IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT.
IN THE WAY WE KNOW WE NEED. TO
TWO WOULD ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE PEOPLE SO THAT THERE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE SITUATIONS.
ON CITY STREETS THAT WERE THAT
WERE DESCRIBED.
SO IT'S A DIFFICULT.
ONE BUT I AM RECOMMENDING AND I
APPRECIATE THE THAT YOU TAKE THE
TOOK THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT
SITTING COUNTIES ARE TO SCHOOL
WILL BE A REAL PARTNER.
WITH US AND WITH HE
STAKEHOLDERS TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM AND FINING SOME PATHWAYS
TO GIVE PEOPLE DIGNITY GIVE
PEOPLE A AT A CHANCE AT LIFE.
AND NOT BE JUST SWEEPING THEM UP
BECAUSE THAT'S THE EASIEST
ANSWER AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT HER
GOAL HERE.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE GOAL
OF OTHER JURISDICTIONS THAT'S
PART OF MY CAN [inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
SO IT'S CHIU MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FIRST OF
ALL I WANT TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF -- FOR
AS USUAL --
IT YOU'RE YOU'RE CAREFUL
ANALYSIS AND AND COMPASSIONATE
LOOK AT THIS ISSUE.
AND I THINK THE SENATE AUTHOR
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS
ARE FILLED ACTED OFFICIALS FROM
SAN BREED --
SUPERVISOR ELECT MANAGEMENT AND
LET ME SAY TO MY COLLEAGUES --
THAT WHILE YOU MAY SEE A THREE
OR FOUR SAN FRANCISCO ELECTED
HERE WE ACTUALLY REPRESENT QUITE
A DIVERSITY OF PERSPECTIVES IN
OUR CITY.
AYE AND THE FACT THAT WE ALL
STAND TOGETHER FOR THIS I THINK
IS SIGNIFICANT.
ARE I ALSO WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
OPPOSITION WITH HIM I OFTEN
AGREE ON MANY ISSUES.
ARE I THINK THE AUTHORS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER.
I WILL SAY IN RESPONSE --
TO THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER -- I
CAN ATTEST THAT SAN FRANCISCO IS
DOING EVERYTHING IT CAN TO TRY
TO ADDRESS.
OF THE MYRIAD OF OTHER POLICY
ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED AS FAR AS
ADDRESSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND TRYING TO MOVE FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND MOVING FOR PROGRESSIVE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM ARE AS
WELL AS TRYING TO HAVE THE MOST --
PROTECTIVE --
POLICIES WHEN IT COMES TO TO
TENANT RIGHTS.
YOU'VE OFTEN HEARD ME COLLEAGUES
SAY THAT --
AS THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE OUR STATE NOT
JUST OUR CITIES BUT OUR STATE IS
IN THE WORST IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE MOST INTENSE.
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE HAVE EVER
EXPERIENCED AND WE OFTEN HEAR
THAT OFTEN.
EXPRESSED PERSPECTIVE THAT THE
DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS DOING
THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
BY SUPPORT THIS IN PART BECAUSE
AS HAS BEEN SAID WITHFOLKS WERE
DYING ON THE STREETS WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO RECYCLING.
DALY AND THEN OUT OF OUR JAIL
SYSTEM IN AND OUT OF OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN AND OUT OF
EMERGENCY ROOMS.
WE HAVE TO TRY DIFFERENT THINGS
AND I DO THINK THIS IS A MODEST
STEP FORWARD I DO THINK IT IS
STRUCTURED AS A PILOT SO AS
ARCHER SAID.
WE WILL BE CAREFULLY MONITORING
THIS WE DO EXPECT THERE TO BE
RESULTS THAT WE CAN MEASURE AYE
AND TRULY UNDERSTAND BUT WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING THAT.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM IN THE MISTER KALRA.
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO OFFER SOME
PERSPECTIVE FROM A CASE I WORKED
ON AT ONE POINT IN TIME AND I
APPRECIATE THAT.
CONSERVATORSHIP AS OUR TOP FIVE
PANEL A FEW OF THEM AND THOSE
AND THEY'LL.
AND IN MY FORMER LIFE PRACTICING
LAW FULL TIME.
AND IT'S A DIFFICULT THING TO
FOR THE STATE TO DEPRIVE
SOMEBODY CELEBRITY [inaudible]
YEAH ON USUALLY IT'S UNDER
PRETTY COMPELLING CIRCUMSTANCES --
I APPRECIATE THE STRUCTURE AS A
PILOT PROGRAM.
I DON'T THINK WE DO ENOUGH FOR
THAT HERE PERSONALLY.
THE COUPLE YEARS I'VE BEEN
SERVING HERE.
I THINK IT'S VALUABLE TO TRY
THINGS OUT ON A MORE LOCALIZED
LEVEL.
STUDY THEM GATHER SOME DATA GETS
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE ABOUT WORKING
HOW CAN BE FIXED.
AND THEN THINK ABOUT SCALING IT
UP TO THE STATEWIDE LEVEL --
BUT THIS THIS BILL IN.
AND WORKING MY WAY THROUGH AND
THAT IS THAT.
IT I AGREE WITH THE CHAIR IT'S
IT'S TOUGH [inaudible]
TOUGH VOTE --
MISS SUPPORT IT APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR FOR TALKING TO ME.
ABOUT AHEAD OF TIME GIVE ME A
CHANCE.
TO PER ON MY RADAR WORK MY WAY
THROUGH IT.
BY I HANDLE THE CASE ON THE
CIVIL SIDE WHERE.
I WAS DEFENDING THE MOM WHO IS
SUED FOR NEGLIGENCE SUPERVISION
OF OF HER ADULT SON HER ADULT
SON HAD BEEN IN THE SYSTEM FIFTY
ONE FIFTY NUMEROUS TIMES.
I HAD SEVERE SCHIZOPHRENIA --
IT WAS KNOWN --
HE ENDED UP WITH NO PLACE TO GO
ANY AND OF BACK IN WITH HER.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW [inaudible]
ASH'S MOM.
AND HE ENDED UP STEALING A
FIREARM FROM.
I HER GARAGE BECAUSE YOUR
HUSBAND PASSED AWAY IN AND WAS
LIKE NO --
OWNED A GUN STORE AND SHE
INHERITED A BUNCH WEAPONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THEY WEREN'T
SECURE VERY WELL.
AND HE ENDED UP STEALING ONE OF
THE WEAPONS AND A MURDERING HIS
NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR.
BECAUSE HE THOUGHT SHE WAS A
VAMPIRE --
YOU KNOW.
WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
SLIPPING THROUGH THE CRACKS?
AND THAT'S THAT'S REAL
[inaudible]
SO.
LET'S DO THIS. THREE OUT WORKS
AND THINK IT WAS CUNNINGHAM
MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES A
MOTIONS ON THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
REALLY TOUGH AND IT'S TOUGH FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED AND ON EVERY
SIDE.
BECAUSE I TRULY SINCERELY
BELIEVE I ONCE TRYING TO DO THE
RIGHT THING [inaudible]
I'M.
AND I'M I'M REALLY GRATEFUL UP
TO THE AUTHOR.
I'D TO WIPE UP CHAIR --
ON THE AMENDMENTS I THINK AS WE
HAVE MISTER CHILD THE AMENDMENTS
GO A LONG WAY --
IT MAKING IT A MUCH BETTER BILL
AND I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW THIS IS.
BUT AGAIN AS OFTEN TIMES THE
CASE YOU'RE TRYING TO THREATEN
NEED ALSO AND THIS IS A REALLY
TOUGH -- ONE
TEND TO TRY TO RECONCILE --
MOVED WITH REALLY DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES HAPPENING IN SO MANY
CITIES.
AROUND OUR STATE I'M.
YOU KNOW THE UP OF THE AND TO
TOUCH ON SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
I THINK OF REALLY REALLY HELPFUL --
HAVING THAT WORKING GROUP MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAD ADVOCATES AT
THE TABLE MAKING SURE.
THAT EVERYONE --
CAN REALLY MONITOR THIS.
VERY CLOSELY IS IS CRITICAL --%
BECAUSE NUMBER OF I AGREE WITH
THE OVERALL PLAN WHICH I THINK
PROBABLY.
MOST OF US AGREEMENT THAT NOT
ENOUGH HAS BEEN DONE IN THE
WHOLE WIDE.
ON A WHOLE WIDE RANGE OF ISSUES
THAT HAS LED US. TO WHERE WE ARE --
IN AT THE END SO IT'S NOT
SPECIFIC TO JUST HOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH.
POST MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES OR
DRUG ADDICTION I'M A IT'S HOW
WE'RE DOING WITH POOR PEOPLE
IT'S OUR DEALING WITH THE INCOME
INEQUALITY AND INEQUITIES AND I
KNOW THAT --
YUP SOUNDS A SAM'S CHO HAU
COMPOSITION ALL TIME HOW WE CAN
GET SOME BY NEIGHBORS TO HELP.
US WITH HOUSING IN AND GET THEM
TO HELP IN IN DEALING WITH SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT.
ARE SOME OF THE BIGGER CITIES
ARE JUST REALLY IN A CRISIS MODE --
TRYING TO DEAL WITH --
AND THAT THAT ONE OF THE OTHER
[inaudible]
THE THE AREAS I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW.
EIGHT HAVING A PRETTY ONE FIFTY
HOLDS IN IN TWELVE MONTHS A LOT.
I I CAN THAT REALLY SPEAKS.
TO AND THE DEGREE TO WHICH
SOMEONE IS REALLY.
STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
[inaudible]
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE FACT THAT
THIS IS OF ALL LIMITED --
FIVE YEAR OF THE PILOT IS A GOOD
THING BUT BECAUSE I WOULD HOPE
THAT IT WOULDN'T BE NEEDED AFTER
FIVE YEARS.
THE OTHERS BECAUSE A SUBSET OF
FOLKS THAT.
ARE HOMELESS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
THAT.
IF IN THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS IF
WE CAN REALLY GET.
THE BULK OF THEM OFF THE STREET
AND GET THEM THE HELP THEY NEED.
THAT.
BUT THIS KIND OF PROGRAM
WOULDN'T BE NECESSARY BECAUSE WE
CAN REDUCE.
THE NUMBERS AND THE AND I WILL
NOT REALLY BE KEEN ON LOOKING AT
THE DATA --
FROM SAM CISCO.
I'VE AND A TO SEE WHAT THE END
RESULT IS.
IS THIS SOMEONE THAT.
RIGHT IS ADAPTED PUBLIC DEFENDER
FROM ELEVEN YEARS SPENDING HALF
THAT TIME OFTEN ON IN DRUG
TREATMENT COURT.
OF I HAVE A VISCERAL REACTION TO
ANY KIND INVOLUNTARY ATTENTION
[inaudible]
AND AT THE SAME TIME AS AS SAM
MISS CUNNINGHAM OF THEM SPOKE OF
HER ARE MANY OCCASIONS.
WHERE A HEARTBREAKING OCCASIONS
WHERE I WANTED TO DO MORE AND I
COULDN'T --
AND I HAD.
MANY CLIENTS DIE.
THAT MEANS.
THAT WHERE ARE THEY PASSED OUT
OPEN CASES AND WE CLOSE THEM
BECAUSE OF THEIR DEATH --
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
WE DON'T TAKE THEIR LIBERTY
SERIOUSLY --
BUT GUARD LISTA BUT IT IS GOING
ON IN THEIR LIFE. ONE OF THE
WORRIES THAT I HAVE THAT ARE
CHAIR OF ALLUDED [inaudible]
TO IS.
A TOOL AND AND FRANKLY YOU KNOW
SAM SAYS GO AT A PARTICULARLY
HAVING OUR MARILLAC SUPERVISOR
LIKE HERE WITH OUR SENATOR.
BUT WITH OUR SUMMIT AND BY THE
WAY -- AS
WAS FOR A FROM A WESTERN CENTER
SAID THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS
THE STATE NEEDS TO DO THAT WE
CAN'T GET ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
BASS NOT THE FAULT OF ANYONE
THAT REPRESENTS SAN FRANCISCO.
AND IN MOST CASES THEY THE STATE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SAM SAW
ONES ARE TRYING TO PUSH --
ON ON STATEWIDE FIXES THAT WE
JUST CAN'T.
GET DONE BECAUSE OF REPRESENT
OTHER BECAUSE JIM WE CAN GET
DONE.
AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT THE FAULT
OF OF THOSE THAT REPRESENT
SAMPRAS'S GO THAT'S FOR SURE --
BUT IT I HAVE SEEN IN SOUNDS AND
SOUND GREAT COUNTY SWEEPS THAT
DON'T ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING.
I OF AND AUTHORITY TO DO SWEEPS
THAT DON'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM --
I'M WORRIED THAT THIS TOOL WILL
BE USED AS A WEAPON --
AND THAT'S WHY THE OVERSIGHT IS
SO CRITICAL.
A BETTER DOES TROUBLE ME THAT NO
ONE'S HERE FROM LA --
IT WOULD BE NICE TO HEAR BUT
THAT THEIR COMMITMENT TO MAKE
SURE [inaudible]
THAT -- BUT
THERE GONNA UPHOLD THE RIGHTS.
BUT OF THESE INDIVIDUALS WERE ON
THEIR STREETS WE KNOW LA HAS ONE
OF THE HAS THE WORST.
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM THAN IN THE
NATION.
SO I. DEATHLY --
WANT TO DO WHATEVER I CAN TO
HELP THEM.
BUT THEY HAVE TO GO.
AND I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW
WHY I KNOW THE FOLKS THAT ARE IS
SENSES GO THAT AND THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
I'M I DON'T KNOW WHO'S GOING TO
BE OVERSEEING THE PROGRAM.
AND THE IT AND IS IT GOING TO BE
USED AS A WEAPON.
I IT WAS JUST ABSENCE GOD I I'D
I'D FEEL FAR MORE ACCOUNTABLE TO
SING LOOKING TO LET.
THAT.
THESE NOBLE COLLECTORS DO WHAT
THEY CAN AT THE CITY LEVEL.
UMMM I KNOW THE TRAUMA BEING
BECAUSE NOW LAKE IS IS FAR.
GREATER THAN TOO MUCH ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE NATION.
UMF GREATER THAN IT IS A SAN
JOSE -- AND
MANY OTHER PLACES --
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE ONE AREA
AT THAT LED.
CHAU IS THE MOST IS HOW IS THIS.
TOOL GOING TO BE USED --
BUT I DO BELIEVE AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT THE AMENDMENTS GO
A VERY LONG WAY --
TO PUT ENOUGH PARAMETERS AND
PROTECTIONS OF THESE INDIVIDUALS --
AND THAT I AM CONFIDENT THAT OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO WILL BE ABLE
TO ADD.
A MEASURE IT AND AND BRING ALL
THE HAPPIEST TOGETHER BOTTOM.
ALTHOUGH THE MAJOR PROBLEMS
THERE'S AREN'T ENOUGH BEDS
THERE'S ON OF HOUSING AND SO
EVEN IF YOU CONSERVE SOMEONE
BREAKING UP ITEM.
I WHICH IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT I'VE HAD WITH THAT WITH
SWEEPS IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY --
IS THAT THEY SLEEP FOLKS AND
THEN THEY JUST.
THEIR BY OTHER BACK THERE OR
THEY'RE IN ANOTHER NEIGHBORHOOD.
I'M YOU KNOW A COUPLE DAYS LATER.
AND SO IT THIS IS THE FACT THIS
IS FOCUS JUST ON SOME.
OF THE OF THE ANOTHER ON A
CERTAIN POPULATION OPPOSED HAVE
MENTAL THAT REALLY JUST CAN'T
CARE FOR THEMSELVES --
IT'S GOOD IN THAT IT'S BUT BUT I
WOULD BE WORRIED THAT.
OF WHOSE DEFINING THAT AND AND
WHO'S USING THIS TOOL.
US SOME ANYWAY I'M RAMBLING
LITTLE THAT BECAUSE IT IS TOUGH.
AND IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE IT'S A
BIG DECISION TO TAKE TO GET THIS
KIND OF AUTHORITY TO GOVERNMENT.
OTHER MATTER WHO IT IS THAT'S IN
THAT SEAT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW WHO'S GOING TO BE IN
THAT SEAT TOMORROW AND AND
THAT'S WHERE.
BECAUSE FOR JOHN TO BUY REALLY
APPRECIATE.
APPRECIATE YOU SENATOR.
AND AND I THINK OUR LEADERS HERE
FROM SAMPSON SKULL FOR BEING
HERE BEING PRESENT.
AND BEING AND COMMITTING THEM TO
ENTER.
YOUR FOCUS ON HELPING HELPING
PEOPLE THAT NEED --
BUT HELP THE MOST.
THANK YOU MISTER MEHTA.
WHAT'S GONNA SPEAK BUT SINCE I
JUST MISSED MY FLIGHT
[inaudible]
SOME.
WHEN I TRY TO MAKE MISTER KALRA
MRS TO YOU HAVE AND I'M CAN I'M
CARE?
NOW I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT THREE
HOURS STUFF NOW --
AYE -- AYE
FIRST WANNA THANK AS CENTER
WINNER FOR BRINGING THIS.
I I WORK ON THIS ISSUE --
FOR FOR NUMBER OF YEARS IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT CONTEXTS AYE
AYE AYE CLERKED.
AFTER THE MENTAL HEALTH COURT IN
SAN DIEGO.
AND WE WORK THESE CASES IS
CONSERVATIVE SAYS THEY ARE TOUGH
CASES I'M I SAW THE PROTECTIONS
THAT WENT INTO IT.
AND WHAT WHAT ALL IT TOOK TO TO
GET A CONSERVATORSHIP AND AND
THE BURDEN IS HIGHS IT SHOULD BE --
AND I THINK PEOPLE STRUGGLED
WITH FAT AS TO WHAT'S.
IN A KIND OF THEM THE MORE
HUMANE APPROACH --
WHEN I BECAME THE HOMELESS
COMMISSIONER FOR SENIOR COUNTY?
AND FOCUSED REALLY --
REALLY HEAVILY ON THE CHRONIC
HOMELESS.
AND I HAD --
AT ACTUALLY THIRTY EIGHT AND
MIGHT KIND OF DIRECT CASELOAD A
FEW WELL.
THIRTY EIGHT TOUGHEST INCENTIVE
CAO.
THREE MOST SERIOUSLY MEANT TO
HER PERCENT HAD SERIOUS MENTAL.
SCHIZOPHRENIA LIKE MERRELL
ACCENT --
AND IT IT WAS DIFFICULT WAS
DIFFICULT GETTING THEM AND
HOUSING SERVICES BY THE WAY WE
GOT A MALL AND BUT I FELT FROM
COME FROM SPENDING ALL THOSE
YEARS CHINA FROM GOING OUT ON
THE STREET.
MYSELF NOT SEEN IN AN OFFICE
TALKING ABOUT UP A GLANCE YOU
MYSELF.
AND TALKING TO THESE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO PERSUADE
THEM TO COME IN AND GET SERVICES
AND GET HOUSING.
IT WAS AN UNBELIEVABLY DIFFICULT
TASK BECAUSE AS AS YOU'D SAID
HOW MARILYN.
SOME DAYS WERE REALLY GOOD DAYS.
AND WE HAVE THESE RATIONAL.
RELATIVELY RATIONAL IS SORT OF
FOR REMOVING DISCUSSIONS AND
THEN THE NEXT DAY WOULD BE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT NUMBER.
ONE THAT --
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
ALMOST A YEAR?
AND AMERICAN BACK IN AND HE HE
DIDN'T RECOGNIZE ME NURSING YOU
NOT IT'S BEEN A YEAR OF THIS --
AND DIDN'T KNOW WHO I WAS.
AND IT YOU KNOW IT SHAKES UP A
LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW AND IT
REALLY MAKES YOU REALIZE THE
LEVEL OF STRUGGLE THAT WE ALL
ARE GOING TO HAVE IN OUR OWN
JURISDICTIONS IN OUR OWN CITIES.
AND COUNTIES ON THIS TOPIC I
CAME TO THE CONCLUSION FROM THAT --
THAT I THOUGHT --
PROVIDING CONSERVATIVE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAS A MORE HUMANE
APPROACH THAT THAT BECAME MY
OPINION AND I GET WHY SOME
PEOPLE.
MAY NOT ALWAYS SHARE BUT I FELT
LIKE THE ONLY WAY WE COULD.
AND WAS IT AND BY THE WAY IT WAS
THE ONLY TIME IN SAN DIEGO'S
HISTORY AT LEAST WE HAVE
SUCCESSFUL HOMELESS PROGRAM.
AND WAS THAT NOW GRANTED AND
THAT WAS WHAT BY THE WAY THAT
WAS WITHOUT THAT.
BUT I THOUGHT.
BECAUSE WE WE WE DIDN'T END UP
HAVING TO USE A CONSERVER SHIPS
BUT I THOUGHT THE ONLY WAY
REALLY TO GET PAST. FOR THE
NUMBER I DON'T HATE.
AND GET TARA THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT WHEN. FIVE HUNDRED
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO AT SOME
POINT START MAKING USE SIR
MAKING A BETTER USE OF THE
CONSERVATORSHIP SYSTEM THAT
WASN'T REALLY BEING USED --
SORT OF WELL.
SO -- I AM
DESPERATE THIS DAY I AND MY
BELIEF IT WILL WORK.
ON CANNELLA FORCING THE PILOT
PROGRAM RESULTS --
YOU KNOW.
AT I WISH SANDY LAND MORMON
INTEREST IN THAT OF I GUESS ONLY
MY COMMENTS TO THAT --
BUT I'M A FRUSTRATED ON THAT
FAUSTO HOMELESS COMMISSIONER WE
BI PARTISAN PILOT PROGRAM I
PROMISE YOU --
BUT IN A VAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY THANKS FOR BRINGING
AT THANKS FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU OF ISRAELI SETTLEMENTS
MCCARTY.
I THINK EVERYTHING THAT'S GOOD
ABOUT IT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED.
I I I WANT TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WHENEVER OR WORKING ON
ANY KIND OF A PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THAT GOES.
BEYOND WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
[inaudible]
THAT THAT.
KIND OF MAKES US FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE IT'S SO GOOD TO
HEAR THE OPPOSITION TO REMIND US
WHY WE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
WHY IT IS WE HAVE TO PROTECT
THOSE CIVIL LIBERTIES WHY IT IS
THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE HAVE THE
THE THE GROUP'S THAT --
THERE THAT THE STAKE HOLDERS ARE
GOING TO BE PRESENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE ALL OF THOSE
SAFEGUARDS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE.
EVEN THOUGH AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT TO TALK TO OUR
OFFICES AND YOU KNEW HOW THE
VOTE WAS GOING TO GO.
BUT YOU ALSO KNOW YOU YOU KNOW
US AND YOU KNOW THE SORTS OF
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US.
SO I DO WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING THERE FOR BEING
THE VOICE.
THAT HAS TO BE THERE TO REMIND
US ABOUT THAT BALANCE
[inaudible]
BUT IT CLEARLY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING.
THE BILL THANK SENATOR.
IF YOU MISSED MCCARTY THANK YOU
AND I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING AT THE JUDICIARY ISSUES
AND I'M A SUB TODAY --
BUT WE DID HEAR THIS IN THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE AT A COUPLE
DAYS AGO AND I I SUPPORT THIS IT
IT'S HARD AND I KNOW.
IT'S A BALANCING ACT BETWEEN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
ADDICTION MENTAL HEALTH.
AND PEOPLE'S GOD GIVEN RIGHTS TO
TO LIVE THEIR LIVES.
AND I'M JUST AT A COUPLE
OBSERVATIONS I KNOW THAT IN THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WITH IT WAS
TIGHTENED UP.
AND AND EVEN MORE SO --
TODAY BUT BUT YESTERDAY CURRENT
AND HEALTHCARE TODAY'S AGO NEVER
WAS.
SENATOR YOU DISCUSSED OTHER
JURISDICTIONS --
NOT HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT WAS THE MANTHAT YOU TOOK
IN THE SENATE WITH SENATOR
HANNAH BETH JACKSON.
I WISH WE DID HAVE AN OPT IN --
OPPORTUNITY FOR COUNTIES AND AND
LIKE YOU SAID DISTRICT CARE THE
THE THRESHOLDS TO SHOW THAT THEY
DO HAVE THE SUPPORT SERVICES AND
THEY'RE GOING TO THE STEPS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AYE I WISH
COUNTIES COULD OPT IN.
AND SHOW THAT THEY'RE FOLLOWING
THOSE STEPS IF NOT.
IT WOULD IT WOULD NOT BE AN
OPTION FOR THE AND THERE CAN BE
SOME ACTION TAKEN AGAINST HIM
FOR NOT FOLLOWING THROUGH
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW WE ALL TALK ABOUT
PERSONAL STORIES JUST LAST NIGHT
I SAW SOMEBODY ON MY STREET.
GOING THROUGH TRASH CANS WHO
KNOCKED ON DOORS FOR MY CAMPAIGN.
I KNOW THIS PERSON.
HOMELESS MOTHER MENTAL ILLNESS
METH ADDICT PSYCHOSIS I THOUGHT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THAT HER FAMILY
WOULD LIKE TO GET HER.
IN A PROGRAM.
SHE KEEPS SAYING NO IT'S BEEN IN
AND OUT OF HOSPITAL.
I DON'T THINK SHE SHE MEETS THIS
THESE THRESHOLDS.
AND WE NEED TO WORK ON HELPING
KNOWS BUT DOUBLING THE AMOUNT OF
TIMES TO COME UNDERSTANDING FOR
YOUR AMENDMENTS AND THEN FROM.
FOUR TO EIGHT IS THAT CORRECT
HAVING TO GO THROUGH.
SOME OF THAT THAT SERIOUS --
SITUATIONS --
I THINK YOU KNOW THOSE ARE CASES
THAT WE SEE ON A REGULAR BASIS
OUR COMMUNITY AND IT IT TAKES A
SERIOUSNESS THAT THIS.
TOOL IS USED.
AND AND I THINK IT MAKES SENSE
AND AND I I WANT FOR ONE WANT.
TO ADVOCATE THAT WE OPEN UP AND
ALLOW COUNTIES DOCTRINE AND
OTHER BORDER SUPERVISORS GO
THROUGH A PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS
AND PROVE THAT THEY HAVE ALL
THESE ELEMENTS LIKE THE OTHER.
GUYS ARE DOING BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST.
SAM JUST GO IN SACRAMENTO I MEAN
IT LA YOU'D WALK AROUND HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SEASON PEOPLE FOR
YOURSELF.
AND I KNOW THAT DOESN'T GET US
OFF THE HOOK FOR DRESSING WITH.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
HOMELESSNESS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE'D GO OF THREE THOSE
WELL BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
I THINK THAT WE CAN IGNORE AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
SOLD.
THANK YOU I I WON'T REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID BECAUSE
I THINK YOU'RE.
CERTAINLY DEMONSTRATED SENATOR
BY YOUR A COMMITMENT ON A WHOLE
HOST OF A LEGISLATION THAT --
YOUR HEART IS DESIGNED TO FOCUS
ON THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS AND
TO TRY TO UP LIFT THEM UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE.
RECEIVING ALL THE PRO --
SERVICES THAT --
THAT CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE --
I AND MISTER CHALLEN I REPRESENT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
SO WE CAN'T EXPLAIN WHY LA
COUNTY ARE HERE TODAY.
BUT WE WILL MAKE OUR SPECIAL
EFFORTS TO COMMUNICATE.
OUGHT TO THE LEADERSHIP AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
OF WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS ARE OF
THE COMMITTEE --
AND TO ALSO COMMUNICATE ARTISTS --
APPOINTMENT THE FACT IT.
THEY DID NOT SEND SOMEONE HERE
TODAY TO REPRESENT THE COUNTY
APPROPRIATELY --
SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
AND I WILL COMPLEMENT OF THE
MAYOR ELECT ON HER ASAP FOR
CISCO GIANT COLORS THIS SEASON
PURPORTING PROBABLY TODAY--
O. CHEN.
AND AND THAT WILL NOT KEEP ME
FROM.
BUT VOTER THROUGHOUT OFTEN.
REPRESENTING THE DODGERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NOTICE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
IT IN AND I WILL KNOW THAT.
SENATOR STERN IS --
A JOINT AUTHORED THAT HE ASKED
THAT LA BE IN IT.
BUT WE HAVE HEARD THAT MUCH FROM
LOS ANGELES I'M NOT SURE HOW
MUCH THEY WANT TO TAKE IT
ADVANTAGE OF THIS BUT IF THEY DO.
AGAIN SINCE IT IS A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT IS UP TO US. TO TO
KEEP TRACK OF I THANK YOU.
SENATOR YOU BECAUSE A COLLEAGUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THIS IS
NOW THE FIFTH TIME THAT I'VE
PRESENTED THE SPELLING COMMITTEE
ALL WITHOUT MY FRIENDS HERE
REALLY GO.
WELL I GOT YOU KNOW REALLY GOING
THROUGH WE GO AROUND TOGETHER
AND WE DEBATED SOUTHERN AND AND
IT'S ALL GOOD BECAUSE THEY ARE
NORMALLY ALLIES ON EVERYTHING --
BUT I THIS WOODSTOCK I AM BY FAR --
THE MOST THOROUGH AND THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION AND I ARE AN
IMPERSONAL BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
THIS IS ABOUT OUR THERE'S ABOUT
PEOPLE.
AND ARE AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
IN DEEP CRISIS AND I KNOW I KNOW
I KNOW THAT TO EMOTIONAL. FOR A
LOT OF US WE ALL LIVE IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THEIR PEOPLE I SEE
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE CASTRO
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WHO OVER YEARS I SEE THEM TO THE
CLIENT IN THE CLIMB DECLINE IN
THERE? ONE DAY THEY'RE NOT THERE
ANYMORE I DON'T KNOW.
TRIED TO GET HELP HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO AND THEY'RE GONE.
I AND THIS IS A HUMAN --
TRAGEDY THAT PLAYS OUT EVERYDAY
NOT JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO AND LA
BUT IN SACRAMENTO IN FRESNO.
AN ORANGE COUNTY AND REALLY
EVERYWHERE IN OUR STATE OUR AND
I DO THINK TRYING SOMETHING.
ADDITIONAL TOOL AS A PILOT
PROGRAM I WILL MAKE SENSE I I
WANNA SAY WITH RESPECT TO LOS
ANGELES I MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT SENATOR STERN.
HERE'S MY JOINT AUTHORED ON THE
BILL AYE HE'S BEEN INVOLVED FROM
THE BEGINNING ARGUE WITH THEM
THEY WOULD BE HERE TODAY BECAUSE
OF OTHER BILL PRESENTATIONS.
OUT WE HAVE BEEN AND ARE IN
COMMUNICATION WITH LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY
WERE HERE TODAY THEY HAVE BEEN.
ANOTHER HEARINGS UP THERE ALSO
I'LL LA EYES WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE SANTIAGO
AND THREE MEN ON A RELATED A
BILL -- SO
LA IS VERY ENGAGE AND I KNOW
THAT THEY ARE VERY COMMITTED UP
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
VOTERS A LOS ANGELES ADOPTING.
A HUGE OF FUNDING ARE MEASURE
FOR HOUSING OF FOR HOMELESS
PEOPLE AND I KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN CHU HAS A BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MONEY
ACTUALLY CAN GET SPENT
IMPLEMENTED.
AYE SO I DO I AM CONFIDENT THAT
LA IS COMMITTED LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO TO IMPLEMENTING THE
BILL WHILE OTHER ARE OTHER
COUNTIES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT THAT
AND I CAN BE AN ONGOING
DISCUSSION.
I YOU KNOW I THINK OF THE
OPPOSITION MADE UP POINT IN AND
EACH OF THESE INDIVIDUALS LIVES.
ARE THEY WERE.
OUT.
THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
THEM IN A MUCH LESS RESTRICTIVE
Y..
AND I AGREE THAT WE AS A STATE
ARE AS A COUNTRY FRANKLY SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE FAILED IN TERMS OF ALLOWING
FOR THE DETERIORATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SAFETY NET FOR NOT
ADDRESSING THE MATH AN OPIOID.
EXPLOSIONS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN
THIS COUNTRY OUR OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND OUR STATE'S
RETREAT FROM PUBLIC HOUSING.
AND FOOD SAFETY NET HOUSING ARE
ARE BROKEN HOUSING POLICY WHERE
AN SRO IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE
THE POOREST OF THE POOR.
USED TO BE ABLE TO LIVE ON A
DISABILITY CHECK NOW RENTS FOR
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH
AN SRO IN SAN FRANCISCO AT
ELEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
BERKELEY.
I'M SURE LA STARTING TO CATCH UP.
OUT WE HAVE THE SYSTEMIC
FAILURES BACK.
COULD HAVE HELPED PREVENT SOME
OF THESE SOMEONE FROM SLEEPING
IN HIS FECES.
ON THE STREET OR AS A SANTIAGO
SAID AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
SOMEONE BEING ON THE STREET WITH
NO TOES.
WE COULD HAVE PREVENTED ALL
THESE THINGS AND WE NEED TO WORK
TO PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING THE
FUTURE BUT WE ARE WHERE WE ARE
NOW.
I'M WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DEEP CRISIS AND ARE.
ARE DYING BEAR CURRENTLY OFTEN
BEING CONSERVED IN A PLACE
CALLED JAIL.
WE KNOW THAT LA COUNTY JAIL IS
THE LARGEST MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER I BELIEVE IN THE UNITED
STATES WE ARE CURRENTLY
CONSERVING PEOPLE.
IN JAIL -- I
WOULD HAVE A DIFFERENT OPTION --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE.
BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU AYE AYE CHIU AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES AYE REYES
AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
SOME WILL IT TAKE THAT MOTION ON
THE PROPOSED THAT CONSENT AGENDA.
THERE'S A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IF YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CHAO.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES.
REYES AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY A SET PHYLLIS OUT THAT
IS S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY ONE WHITE
HOUSE SKI.
THIS MCGUIRE HAD TO GO START OFF
THE HEARING HOPEFULLY HE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK SO WE CAN FINISH BY
BUSINESS.
HE'S ASKING FOR IN URGENCY
BECAUSE HE PUT IN EVEN THOUGH
HE'S NOT HERE JUST YET I'LL TAKE
A MOTION ON ADDING AN URGENCY
BECAUSE TO S. B..
ONE SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU SO
RIVERS IS OUR SECOND.
AND A SECOND THIS JUST ADDING
THE URGENCY WILL NEED MISTER
MCGUIRE TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
THE BUILT OVER THAT'LL GO
QUICKLY SO ON ADDING URGENCY.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
THINK ITS URGENCY WILL BE ADDED
TO S. B. ONE SEVENTY FIVE AND IF
WE CAN.
IF WE MISTER MAGUIRE CENTER
MILLER WILL BE BACK QUICKLY AND
THEN WE CAN FINISH UP.
IT HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT --
YES IF SOMEBODY'S WILLING TO
PRESENTS OR WILL.
ABOUT AS IS A MEMBER MCGUIRE STE
THIS WHERE'S SENATE MCGUIRE
STAFF HERE.
OKAY IS THE IS THE ARTIST Y.
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
BUT AND LET'S DO ADD ONS WHILE
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
SO ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. NINE
EIGHTY FOUR SKINNER.
BECAUSE I HAVE TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
STAR [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NO CHAU.
CHAU AYE KILEY [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I
SO.
MISTER CARR IS GONNA START ON
BEHALF y
START TO PRESENT THE BILL.
SO WE CAN MOVE INTO GETTING THE
WITNESSES HEARD.
IF YOU JUST.
GIVE US THE THE GIST OF THE BILL.
AND EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS BEHALF
OF CENTER MCGUIRE SO FOR SENATE
MCGUIRE STAFF HE IS ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS CORRECT.
OKAY WHICH IS JUST HERE TO OPRAH.
SO WE WE ALREADY VOTED NEAR
SIKASSO THAT'S FIGHTS IF YOU
JUST INTRODUCED BILL.
THIS HOWEVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M PRIDE THIS ITEM NUMBER ONE
SP.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE OKAY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
REGARDING DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
CANYON SPRINGS COMMUNITY
FACILITY APPEAR TO WITNESSES
HERE -- TO
PRESENT NOT HAVE THEM INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND CARRY ON THANK
YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS NANCY PARTS MAN AYE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WE'RE
ACTUALLY THE SOURCE OF THE BILL.
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
SENATOR REQUIRES SP.
ONE JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THE
SAFETY NET SERVICES TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE VERY COMPLEX
NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY WE
RELEASED A SAFETY NET PLAN.
ON AND TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS
PART OF A SAFETY NET PLAN WAS
DEVELOPING NEW RESOURCES --
THIS WOULD ACTUALLY PROVIDE US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A BRIDGE
OF SUPPORT SERVICES AT CANYON
SPRINGS TO MEET THE COMPLEX
NEEDS.
UNTIL WE HAVE THE OTHER SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS I'M IN OPERATION
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE
DANIEL SEVERE NO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES AS THE
DIRECTOR SAID IT'S I'M MEANT TO
FILL A NEED FOR SERVICES.
IT'S ALL HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AS FOLKS WOULD RECEIVE
SERVICES IN THE CURRENT
LOCATIONS SO FROM REGIONAL
CENTER PERSPECTIVE THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE.
THESE MUCH NEEDED SERVICES FOR
FOLKS IN CRISIS ME THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
EVELYN ABA HASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT I'M
JUST A QUICK NOTE THIS FACILITY
IS A LITTLE BIT LARGER THAN THE
CURRENT FACILITIES SO WE WOULD
JUST RECOMMEND CAREFUL OVERSIGHT.
I'M BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN TRANSITION
OUT OF THE OUT BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND WITH THE LARGER
FACILITY LIKE THIS.
HAS LESS HOME LIKE SO JUST NOT
JUST A POINT POINT THAT OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU INNOCENT SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SINGER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE PREPARED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU WELL WITH THE DIRECTOR
HERE.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE OFF THE
HOOK YEAH SECOND SECRETS I'VE
RELIEF.
ALRIGHT NO QUESTIONS SO THERE'S
A MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
THANK YOU AND THAT IS AS AMENDED
WHICH WE'VE ADDED THE URGENCY
BECAUSE YOU MAY CLOSE.
BUT THAT'S RIDER INDEED.
KALRA PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
CUNNINGHAM CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHIU HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I REYES.
REYES AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT PHYLLIS OUTS THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA FOR YOUR INDULGENCE
[inaudible] TO WE HAVE
EVERYTHING.
PROGRESS AREN'T THE POLICE FOR
NOTHING.
SO WE NEED MISTER KILEY MR CHIU
FOR FINAL VOTES OUT MISTER TO SO
THIS IS SB ONE SEVENTY FIVE ITEM
NUMBER ONE MCGUIRE.
CUNNINGHAM CHU CHU AYE.
KILEY.
SO MISTER KILEY SO FIRST OF ALL
THE CONSENT AGENDA WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE KILEY.
KILEY AYE
.
SO ITEM NUMBER ONE SP ONE
SEVENTY FIVE MCGUIRE CUNNINGHAM
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TO S. B. NINE EIGHTY
FOUR SKINNER KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO.
I'VE NEVER THREE SB TEN FORTY
FIVE WIENER AND STERN KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE.
AND ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN STERN.
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
THANK YOU THAT IS OUR BUSINESS
FOR THAT TODAY THANKS FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WE ARE ADJOURNED